the jurogan experience people who are
from there who come to america who
understand the dangers of it
it's it's a very eerie warning yeah you
know i had melissa channing on my
podcast yeah she was described
i follow her she's great she's really
great yeah and but her
worries about china are you know like a
lot of people like yeah yeah yeah
but like no no she she really actually
understands what the dangers are yeah
and that's the dangers of accepting
authoritarianism
yeah authoritarianism in this country is
like
there's a lot of people that like it
because it silences their opponents
right like this what's going on right
now with like parlors getting shut down
and you know amazon pulls it from their
servers
and then apple pulls it off of their uh
app store and then google pulls it off
the google play store and everybody's
like yeah
good they're spreading hate like hmm
what percentage is spreading hate like
what's the numbers and
is this is this wise that we shut down
all discourse that you agree with like
yeah it's it's not good if someone gets
on there and they they're talking about
violence
against the government or violence
against individuals or
or they're spreading racist ideas or
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing that's
that's that that that disturbs people
and angers people you're right
that's not good but i do not think
that the solution is to shut them down
because
the real problem is that it sets a weird
precedent
it sets a precedent where the people
that are in power can decide that
something is wrong speak
something is bad and you can just
eliminate it completely
yeah and then when things like that
happen they keep
going they don't just stop at that they
don't stop at things that we can all
agree or
are terrible they they go to things that
maybe you don't think are terrible right
but other people do think are terrible
and then they keep going further than
that you see this with the left like
there's a lot of people that
claim to be leftists they claim to be
left-wing but they're not quite
left-wing enough
and so they get taken out by people who
are more left-wing
and it gets weird because it becomes
this like sort of like political
ideological
wrestling match yeah for control of like
what is the left
what is the center yeah where is the
right if you disagree with anything on
the left you're the right
right you might be extreme right right
yeah i know that you're nazi if you did
yes
but i think it what you're saying
already happened
because with this incident you're going
like okay we blame donald trump's the
president
his rhetoric was kind of you know you
can interpret it as like he kind of gave
them license
to go do that so shouldn't the bo the
buck stop with
donald trump like donald trump that's
even a little bit of a debatable thing
you're going like he was speaking
legally you're going like
that's the first amendment thing he was
speaking he said peacefully you go over
there there it's
gives mixed signals of course in my
opinion is he says we have to be strong
you have to go
march to the capitol he gives mixed
signals and he says like we have to do
this correctly we have to respect our
great country like
whoa whoa whoa what was that [ __ ] you
said the other day right you said
that they don't respect anything other
than strength right like you said
go march towards the cat you you're
firing people up and you're firing
people up but they live with their mom
they're in the basement yeah they have
no [ __ ] job their identity is
entirely associated with this movement
yeah no my opinion is that
but i'm saying legally it's debatable
like what he said
you could argue in court but then the
buck should stop there i mean
it's already happening where they're
going oh no let's take let's take this
opportunity to shut down parliament
let's take this
they're going after andy knows book now
let's get that out of stores
let's uh they want to keep going yeah
because like it's uh this orgy of kind
of like let's
shut down this stuff that leads to and
you're like wait a second
how can you prove it leads to that i
mean idiots are gonna do what idiots do
like and to me that was a coup attempt
that was a coup attempt by guys who
believe
like that's what you'd expect a coup
attempt would look like by guys who
believe like that
hillary clinton's a shape-shifter and
she turns into a reptile that's what
you'd imagine it would look like what
are we doing okay let's [ __ ]
let's go in there with trump flags and
take selfies and
so it's so dumb and let's go kidnap
nancy pelosi with
zip ties zip ties stacks of zip ties
like more zip ties than there are
members of the senate yeah if anything
it was just like an
inept coup attempt yeah well it's losers
yeah it's losers who decided this is
their moment in the sun
yeah and meanwhile they're they're all
covet deniers so they're not wearing
masks
because they're so [ __ ] stupid catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify watch back
catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience